[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a romantic comedy film
called timer spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
[Music]
in the near future a device is developed
which allows one to see the exact time
they will meet their soulmate it is
called the next revolutionary step in
digital matchmaking by many a facility
called the timer offers such service to
common people they insert a chip on your
wrist that counts down to the day you
meet your soulmate when two soul mates
come in close proximity the timer goes
off letting them know that they have met
each other however the timer won't start
until both people have gotten the chip
embedded in their wrists oona is a los
angeles orthodontist who has an
unblinking timer meaning that her
soulmate isn't equipped with one she has
come to the timer office with her recent
boyfriend to find out if he is really
the one the worker named matchmaker
patty is good friends with una because
she is one of their frequent customers
una has brought several guys to the
facility in hopes of finding her
soulmate her boyfriend is clearly
nervous before going in because if their
timer doesn't match they will have to
break up paddy makes him sign a document
and embeds his wrist with the implant it
starts to blink almost immediately
showing them that he has two years left
to meet his soulmate oona looks at her
timer hoping for it to start blinking
but it never does her boyfriend is glad
that he will meet his soulmate right
when he finishes medical school after
finding out they are not the one for
each other they break up and go their
separate ways una's stepsister and
roommate steph has a timer that says she
will not meet her soulmate for over 15
years since she isn't going to wait for
that long steph's lifestyle includes one
night stands with men who are only
looking for a fling like her one day una
is at a grocery store when the cashier
named mikey starts a conversation with
her his compliments flatter oona but she
notices he already has a timer that has
a specific date on it meaning that he is
not her soulmate mikey also notices her
timer but suggests they can still see
each other because soul mates are in the
future anyway at night the sisters go to
their parents for dinner but steph is
late as always she notices una is sad
about her ex-boyfriend and advises her
to resort to one-night stands until she
meets the one at their parents house
everyone is excited for their younger
brother jessie to get his timer embedded
for the first time they have even
invited a matchmaker to celebrate the
event together the matchmaker plants the
implant and it immediately shows jesse
only has three days left to meet his
soulmate everyone is happy for him but
oona thinks it's unfair she
congratulates her little brother and
leaves without waiting for dinner she
drives back to the grocery store to meet
mikey at first she hesitates to go in
but does it anyway mikey is left stunned
when she asks him out he quickly asks
his co-worker to take his place and
follows her back to the car the car ride
to mikey's home is awkward as the two
don't have anything in common to talk
about they finally reach mikey's
apartment and are greeted by four of his
roommates the house is trashed with beer
bottles and tissue papers which makes
una rethink her decision she also tells
mikey that she is turning 30 soon and
regrets it instantly when she is about
to leave mikey persuades her to stay and
the two finally kiss but she notices his
timer again which only has four months
left in it oona realizes what she is
doing is wrong and leaves after
apologizing the following day she is
surprised by mikey coming to her job as
a patient he assumes that she doesn't
like him because he is a cashier and
explains that he does music as well ooh
mikey is getting more hopeless by the
second he tries to persuade her claiming
that the timer only shows you a definite
path and life is about detours but una
bluntly states that he is not the one
for her so she is not wasting time on
him moreover she feels like he is
cheating on his future soulmate at night
she goes on a blind date with a man but
is clearly very bored he only talks when
she asks him questions so the date ends
on a bad note to get over it una goes to
a club and meets mikey yet again he is a
drummer in the band performing at the
club the two make eye contact and end up
in mikey's room at the end of the day as
they make out his roommates arrive at
the house and disturb them mikey asks
all of them to shut up because this is
the only chance he will get with someone
like una who is way out of his league
meanwhile steph is at her job as a
receptionist at a nursing home when a
handsome man named dan walks in she is
interested in him but is disappointed to
notice he doesn't have a timer at home
she asks una about her night and is
proud of her for finally getting with a
guy she also advises her to never meet
him again because she might get hurt it
is finally the day una's brother gets to
meet his soulmate his parents excitedly
send him to school but the whole day
passes without his timer ringing when he
finally returns home their housemate
introduces him to her daughter soledad
and the timer finally goes off while
jesse's mother is excited soledad's
parents rudely leave the premises with
her in the evening oona is about to
return home from work when mikey
startles her she hits him in the face
but quickly composes herself and the two
drive back to her house oona kisses him
after making sure steph isn't around
starting then they start to date oona
goes to his house frequently and makes
friends with his roommates she tells him
about her biological father who is a
music producer she hasn't talked to him
since he and his mother broke up one day
at work steph gets yelled at by her boss
for not receiving calls dan lies to him
and gets her out of the situation he is
clearly interested in steph but she
seems to not care still she asks him out
planning to set up a date between him
and una she tells una to be at the club
in the evening because she hasn't been
out lately oona feels bad for not
telling staff about mikey but she is
afraid of being judged later that day
steph and dan wait for una at the bar
for a long time but she doesn't come
instead she hangs out with mikey in her
room steph and dan talk for a long time
dan tells her about his wife who died
three years ago he believes that she was
his soulmate so he never had to plant
the timer on his wrist as the
conversation continues they start to
like each other but when steph returns
home she is furious at una for
abandoning her she sees mikey in her
room and figures out that they have been
seeing each other in secret things get
heated when the sisters begin to argue
about mikey's timer he interrupts them
and reveals that his timer is actually a
sticker that he bought so he would feel
included he doesn't actually believe in
timers and would never get one oona is
still in utter shock and mad at him for
lying to her all along she furiously
asks him to leave their time together
had only been enjoyable because she
thought it wouldn't last long now that
she knows he doesn't have a timer she
feels betrayed for the next week she
doesn't try to contact him but is
miserable at the same time she finally
decides to talk to him and tells him
that she is sorry they meet at una's
parents house for thanksgiving their
housemaid and her daughter have also
gathered for the meal mikey knows how to
speak in spanish so he gets along with
them easily oona answers all the
questions that her parents ask mikey and
doesn't let him speak it is evident that
she is ashamed of being in a
relationship with someone so young and
naive and a drummer meanwhile dan and
steph meet a couple of times and start
dating oona on the other hand is now
unsure how she feels about mikey
moreover her mother urges her to find
out if mikey is her soulmate as soon as
possible one day he suddenly confesses
that he loves her but una panics and
leaves she and steph then go to see
una's biological father rick they are
received by a young woman who happens to
be rick's girlfriend the first few
minutes are awkward because una hasn't
talked to him for a long time then she
bluntly asks him why he never got a
timer the man shows her the timer on his
wrist and tells her he has one but he
still has some time left to meet his
soulmate then his girlfriend tells them
that she had her timer removed because
she loves rick and doesn't care what the
timer says the sisters are inspired by
her so they rush to get theirs removed
promising to live their life without
depending on a stupid countdown
matchmaker kate is in utter shock to
find out the girls want to remove their
timers she and the manager warn them
that if the device is removed once they
cannot replant it so this will be their
last chance of finding true love steph
says she doesn't care and finally
removes hers but when it is una's turn
she hesitates seconds before it is
removed the timer starts to beep
it turns out that her soulmate got his
timer embedded right then uno only has
five hours to meet him she decides to
leave it on for that time out of
curiosity but steph gets mad at her the
following day is their shared birthday
at night oona's countdown stops meaning
she will meet her soulmate the next day
their mother organizes a birthday party
for the two of them she has invited dan
and mikey both steph arrives at the
house first and hangs out with dan mikey
on the other hand is busy translating a
conversation between the housemaid and
oona's mother they decide to stay as
boss and worker and let their kids take
their relationship further themselves
when oona arrives at the party her timer
rings along with dan's meaning that he
is her soulmate an annoyed staff storms
off to the kitchen while mikey leaves
for his house dan follows steph and asks
her if she is okay oona joins the two to
talk about the situation steph starts to
yell at una for always getting
everything she wants in life she
believes that una has taken away dan who
is the only person she was ever
interested in the sisters get into a
fight which ends when una tells steph
she is her best friend and she doesn't
want dan
after una leaves dan tells steph that he
got a timer because it was important for
her and that he doesn't care for her
sister the following morning oona goes
to meet mikey at his house she shows him
that she got her timer removed because
she wants to be with him mikey is
confused at first he's a drummer after
all but then finally kisses her the next
day steph wakes una up and they solve
their differences in the last scene una
then goes out on a run and
coincidentally meets dan they talk for a
while and find out they have a lot in
common but at last they laugh and go
their separate ways subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching